they for stat trucks are out it could  only be the leaders debate the only  leaders debate where the two main  contenders for Prime Minister are  face-to-face but they're face-to-face  with a cast list of another five leaders  a kaleidoscope a rainbow no less you can  see the anchors of the main national  news channels you can see people who  around the world have come to report  this important insight and I think right  now the watchword is expectations  management key figures in the parties  are sort of phoning up right now ticket  this is maybe not quite the right format  oops certain people do well in the first  debate and do badly in the second debate  you know management of expectations is  key to determining who gets momentum out  of a situation like this if there's an  omen perhaps look at that a team in red  that's been down in the dumps after a  change of management or perhaps they're  on the rise again we'll find out at the  debate